[Musique]
et notre invité politique ce matin c'est
Olivier fort bonjour merci beaucoup
d'être avec nous député premier
secrétaire du Parti socialiste on est
ensemble pendant 20 minutes pour une
interview en partenariat avec la presse
régionale représenté par chrelle
Bertrand du groupe La Dépêche bonjour
bonjour bonjour bonjour à vous aussi on
va évidment parler de la loi immigration
Olivier fort le Parlement l'a donc
adopté hier un vote du Sénat un vote de
l'Assemblée nationale si vous aviez un
mot pour qualifier la journée d'hier
qu'elle
serait-il basculement basculement parce
que ce qui s'est passé est très grave en
fait c'est le renoncement par le
Président de la République à tous les
principes qui ont fondé notre pays
depuis la Révolution française c'est
aussi la fin de quelque chose que nous
avons connu jusqu'ici le barrage
républicain et qui a permis à Emmanuel
Macron d'être élu à deux reprises
président de la République parce que je
vois mal comment aujourd'hui on pourrait
demander à un écteur de gauche de
joindre ses voix à la droite macroniste
pour un scrutin alors même que en
réalité ils ne sont pas un barrage ils
ont baissé le pont Levie et ils ont fait
rentrer dans la loi tous les principes
pour lesquels en fait Jean-Marie Le Pen
se battait depuis 40 ans voilà ce qui
s'est passé hier et c'est à regret que
je le dis et j'espère maintenant cont
tenu de ce qu'est la crise interne à la
majorité relative que le Président de la
République aura cette présence d'esprit
ce soir d'annoncer que il ne promulgue
pas la loi Jacques Chirac en son temps
sur le CPE qui avait fracturé le pays
avait fait le choix alors même que la
loi avait été votée et bien avait fait
le choix de ne pas promulguer et bien je
souhaite vous lui demandez vous appelez
ce matin le président de la République à
ne pas promulguer cette loi j'appelle le
président de la République à ne pas
promulguer la loi et à tenir compte des
mouvements d'opinion qui sont nombreux y
compris dans son propre camp de gens qui
lui disent que ça n'est pas possible
d'aller aussi loin et de ne rien régler
sur le fond et d'accéder à toutes les
demandes et de donner une victoire
idéologique au RN hier soir si le RN
n'avait pas voté avec les droites et
bien le texte ne passait pas ils ont ils
ont constitué de fait une majorité
parlementaire sur la question migratoire
qui est une majorité RN LR Renaissance
et bien c'est ind digne on aurait pu
dire la même chose si le RN n'avait pas
voté la motion de rejet de la gauche la
motion de rejet ne passait pas non plus
mais quel rapport faites-vous entre une
motion de rejet avec la conjonction de
votes qui n'ont rien à voir les uns avec
les autres vous avez des gens qui
considéraent que la loi n'était pas
assez dure et d'autres qui consident
qu'elle considérit qu'elle était déjà
trop dur et donc vous avez eu en fait
une conjonction de vote sur une motion
de rejet mais là ce n'est pas la même
chose vous avez en fait des gens qui
votent ensemble un texte qui a un
contenu mais est-ce qu'elle a pas fait
un politique mar Le Pen au Sénat sur un
texte qui était à peu près similaire on
va revenir sur le fond mais l'accord de
la CMP c'est à peu près le texte du
Sénat les les sénateurs Aren s était
opposé lors du vote du Sénat est-ce que
là elle a pas fait un coup politique en
essayant de récupérer un accord mais ne
cherchez pas partout là des histoires de
politique aie et cetera regardez le fond
du texte que dit le texte il donne pour
la première fois la possibilité de dire
qu'il y a une préférence nationale en
France rompant avec le principe d'égal
qui est un principe qui a fondé notre
République et donc vous avez là en fait
non plus une différence philosophique
entre la macronie et l'extrême droite
vous avez simplement une différence qui
relève en fait du nombre d'années à
partir desquelles on peut accéder au
droit c'est la seule chose qui est
différencie vous avez
là ça existe déjà pour certaines
allocations le RSA par exemple il faut 5
ans présence en France avant de le
toucher quand vous êtes étranger par non
on parle pas de la même chose là on
parle des droits qui sont les droits
fondamentaux pour une famille à pouvoir
vivre en famille sur le regroupement
familial c'est la possibilité aussi pour
une mère célibataire de pouvoir toucher
des allocations pour simplement élever
ses enfants comment voulez-vous
aujourd'hui que nous acceptions en fait
de de revenir sur tout ce qui a même y
compris sur les principes fondateurs de
la sécurité sociale en fait nous avons
après la Seconde Guerre mondiale adopté
des principes qui sont des principes
clairs et sur lesquels le président de
la République a choisi de revenir il met
fin à ce qui a été le consensus du
Conseil National de la Résistance voilà
ce qu'il fait mais alors justement lui
et la majorité disent si on fait cette
loi c'est pour éviter que les électeurs
ne votent encore plus massivement pour
Marine Le Pen puisqu'il y a une demande
dans l'opinion publique d'une plus
grande fermeté mais euh donc il faudrait
pour éviter Marine Le Pen faire Marine
Le Pen à sa place c'est ce que je
comprends de ce que vous dites moi je
crois que si nous voulons oui je bien je
accuser très directement Gérald armman
mais euh qu'est-ce que cette loi résout
en réalité est-ce que vous pensez
sérieusement que cette loi va permettre
de juguler en quoi que ce soit les
mouvements migratoires à quoi sont dus
les mouvements migratoires ils sont dus
au réchauffement climatique ils sont dus
à la situation géopolitique dansbre de
pays à la misère à l'échange inégal
entre le Nord et le Sud voilà les
questions qu'il faut se poser alors
qu'est-ce qu'on fait pour répondre à
cette inquiétude des Français qui
considère que l'arrivée d'étrangers sur
notre territoire est est problématique
mais ce que je viens de vous dire on
essaie de régler les questions à leur
racine qu'est-ce qui fait que les gens
aujourd'hui prennent le risque de périr
en mer Méditerrané et alors même que ils
avaient une vie une culture un village
des amis une famille qu's abandonnent
pour pouvoir venir en France pourquoi le
font-ils ils le font simplement parce
qu'il fuit quelque chose et donc la
question ça n'est pas de savoir comment
est-ce qu'on fait pour mettre un mur à
l'entrée en fait de notre territoire la
réalité c'est qu'on sait très bien que
rien n empêchera ces gens-là de venir et
de chercher un avenir là où ils en nont
pas donc c'est comment est-ce qu'on fait
pour donner un avenir à ces gens à
l'endroit où ils se trouvent vous savez
que dans les prévisions qui sont faites
sur les mouvements migratoires on ne
parle pas de quelques centaines de
personnes qui vont venir qui vont
chercher à venir sur les les côtes
européennes on parle à l'échéance 2050
d'un milliard d' d'êtres humains qui
vont quitter leur pays pour pouvoir
échapper au réchauffement climatique 1
milliard d' alors soyons
laart iront d'une régutre dans le propre
pays mais d'autres iront en fait dans le
pays voisin et d'autres chercheront
après parce que ça provoquera des
conflits innombrables qui seront des
conflits de territoire et bien d'autres
chercheront à venir jusqu jusqu'en
Europe et donc qu'est-ce qu'on fait ce
que vous dites fait peur à un certain
nombre de Français mais bien sûr mais je
comprends que ça puisse effrayer
simplement ce que je dis c'est que on ne
traite pas ces questions là simplement
en expliquant qu'on va priver de droit
les gens qui sont déjà en France on est
en train de fabriquer quoi vous êtes en
train de fabriquer enfin vous vous êtes
pardon à chaque fois je veux pas vous
prendre un parti mais que fait cette loi
est-ce qu'elle règle quelque chose non
elle dit simplement qu'il y a des gens
qui auraient pu être régularisés qui
vont être renvoyés à la clandestinité
renvoyer à clandestinité ça veut dire
quoi ça veut dire simplement que ces
gens-là et bien seront en fait les
proies de l'économie parallèle de la
drogue de la prostitution de tout ce qui
peut être en fait exercé dans la
clandestinité parce qu' n'auront pas
accès en fait à un travail légal voilà
ce qui va se passer et donc est-ce que
ces gens-là seront renvoyés en leur pays
la réponse vous le savez très bien c'est
non il y a aujourd'hui 60000 au qtf
obligation de quitter le territoire
français qui sont prononcés chaque année
il y en a combien qui sont exercés
réellement moins de 10 % pourquoi parce
que tout simplement en fait il faut des
laisser passer consulaire et que les
pays d'origine se refusent à les donner
donc est-ce qu'on pense que demain avec
cette loi les choses vont changer la
réponse est clairement NON et donc cette
loi ne résou rien elle crée des zones
grises plus importantes elle fragilise
et précarise des populations entières
qui vont vivre dans la clandestinité et
qui seront les proies en fait de tous
les salopards qui aujourd'hui cherchent
à exploiter la misère et nous aurons en
fait une population qui va en fait voilà
qui va vivre dans la marginalité et vous
n'aurez absolument rien réglé ce texte
il met aussi en place des
régularisations pour les travailleurs
sans papier dans les méti tention la fin
des mineurs dans les centres de
rétention vous avez entendu géralmanin
hier il vous dit on met en place des
mesures que la gauche n'a jamais mis en
place ça en fait si vous avez suivi
l'actualité et je sais que vous l'avez
suivi vous savez très bien que sur les
mineurs dans les centres de rétention ça
n'est pas lié à la loi c'est lié en fait
à une décision de justice qui intime
l'obligation à l'état français d'en
finir avec cette incarcération de mineur
donc ça n'a rien à voir avec gerérald
Darman mais vous avez entendu ce qu'il
vous a dit il vous a cité ces deux
articles notamment ces deux mesures en
tout cas en disant mais nous on le met
en place la gauche ne l'a jamais fait
mais c'est pas vrai c'est déjà possible
de régulariser dans les métiers non
seulement en tension mais dans les
métiers tout courts simplement
aujourd'hui il y a un verrou qui est
posé par le fait que c'est l'employeur
qui doit accepter en fait de parrainer
en quelque sorte son sang papier demain
ça ne sera plus le cas et ça c'est
plutôt positif mais ils ont tellement
restreint le dispositif que ils ont non
plus accepté l'idée que ce soit en fait
une ce soit un droit opposable c'est
c'est simplement maintenant à
la à la main du préfet et donc à la main
de l'arbitraire préfectoral qui
acceptera dans certains cas dans
d'autres refusera et donc rien ne sera
en fait garanti à qui que ce soit et
donc on est là en train de fabriquer
effectivement du désordre là où trou grâ
à vos yeux dans ce texte mais écoutez je
cherche avec beaucoup de difficultés ce
qui pourrait trouver grâce à mes yeux
parce qu'en réalité même je vois que
enfin regardez les présidents en fait
des grands grandes écoles de commerce à
chaussé les sec et cetera qui hier ont
pris la parole ce qui est rare dans
notre vie publique qui jamais ne
prennent position sur quoi que ce soit
ont expliquait que on allait priver la
France de son attractivité que des
étudiants étrangers ne pourraient plus
venir en France parce que désormais on
demandera une caution pour être sûr
qu'il reparent et donc on sélectionnera
y compris par l'argent les étrangers qui
peuvent venir en France alors même que
nous avons besoin de cet afflux je vous
rappelle qu'en 2018 c'est le même
gouvernement qui avait appelé au
contraire à ouvrir les frontières aux
étudiants étrangers pourquoi parce que
les étudiants étrangers qui étudient en
France pour une part d'entre eux ils
participeront demain à la création de
richesse et pour une part d'entre eux
ils seront nos ambassadeurs partout dans
le monde voilà ce que en fait c'est une
politique de gribouille c'est une
politique qui hélas est une politique
qui est une politique sur un fond qui
est un fond raciste xénophobe alors vous
avez demandé au président de la
République de ne pas promulguer la loi
vous avez aussi annoncé que vous alliez
saisir le Conseil constitutionnel est-ce
que vous savez déjà sur quel motif il y
a toute une série en fait de
dispositions qui contreviennent
totalement à nos règles alors à la fois
les cavaliers donc des des des
amendements qui navaient pas de rapport
direct avec l'objet de la loi au départ
et puis vous avez toute une série de
dispositions qui selon nous sont
inconstitutionnelles parce que ell elles
ne répondent pas à la Constitution et
elles violent un certain nombre de
principes notamment le principe
d'égalité mais Géral armanin le dit
qu'il y a des dispositions
inconstitutionnelles ou Géral armanin a
cherché à rassurer sa propre majorité
enfin sa propre minorité présidentielle
pour essayer de lui dire écoutez on voit
des trucs qui sont horribles mais ENF
fermer les yeux bouchez-vous le nez
c'est pas grave de toute façon le
Conseil constitionnel fera le ménage
franchement ça n'est pas très
responsable c'est même inoui de voir un
ministre qui vient et qui dit ma loi
elle est super mauvaise mais ne vous
inquiétez pas votez là les yeux fermés
parce que de toute façon d'autres font
travailler à notre place quelle est
cette conception du votre démarche
pourrait faire tomber l'ensemble du
texte ou uniquement certaines mesures
j'imagine certaines mesures je ne pense
pas que que le Conseil constitionnel
puisse détruire l'ensemble de ce qui a
été fait mais c'est bien malheureux
parce que en réalité enfin c'est pas son
travail il n'a pas lui vocation à faire
autre chose que du droit mais pour la
première fois je le dis aussi je le
répète pour la première fois nous avons
en fait des un législateur qui accepte
de revenir sur les grands principes qui
ont fondé l'identité de notre pays
depuis la Révolution française Emmanuel
Macron hier disait que si le texte était
adopté avec les voix duurn il ne voulait
pas qu'il demanderait une deuxième
délibération au Conseil des minist
gr au vo du R vous lui demandez de le
faire du coup mais bien sûr enfin je lui
demande de ne pas promulguer allons
clairement directement à l'objectif vous
avez hier et les calculs sont simples à
faire comment dire vous n'êtes pas
d'accord sur les calculs lui ça n'a pas
été adopté avec les vois du R mais
attendez vous avez fait le calcul
vous-même tout dépend comment on
interprète la majorité en fait non en
fait c'est très simple dans la vie
publique quand vous cherchez à voir
savoir qui a la majorité vous prenez
l'ensemble des suffrages exprimés vous
divisez par de et vous mettez une voix
de plus plus et c'est ça qui fait la
majorité hier il fallait 268 voix pour
pouvoir être majoritaire sur ce texte
ils en ont eu avec les voix de du MoDem
de renaissance d'horizon et DLR ils en
ont eu SEP de moins et donc ils ont
adopté ce texte évidemment grâce au voix
du RN c'est simple c'est enfantin pas
besoin d'avoir fait en fait
Polytechnique pour le comprendre et tous
ceux qui vous disent le contraire
mentent parce que comme depuis le début
ils mentent systématiquement sur ce
texte ouais il disent que si Leuren
s'était abstenu ça si si si Paris était
enfin vous connaissez la formule avec
des si on peut tout faire y compris
expliquer que le RN n'existe pas Bruno
retaillot il dit qu'il y a un seul texte
qui a été voté c'est celui du Sénat et
que donc le texte final ne pouvait que
se rapprocher du texte du Sénat
répondant à ça à la critique de
droitisation est-ce que vous vous avez
pas contribué à la droitisation du texte
en votant cette motion de rejet du coup
vous savez que c'est complètement faux
vous savez que une commission mixte
paritaire de toute façon elle est
convoqué ok motion de rejet ou pas il y
aurait eu une commission mixte paritaire
sa face que président accepte l'idée que
avec la motion de rejet c'était un
signal qui devait lui permettre de
retirer complètement le projet mais là
le seul texte qui avait une légitimité
parlementaire du coup Ctait celui du
Sénat non en fait il y avait deux textes
il y avait le texte du Sénat et puis y
avait le texte issu de la commission des
lois de l'Assemblée puisque la
commission des lois a délibéré et vous
savez très bien que la commission mixte
paritaire elle a un mandat qui est un
mandat large on c à la carte blanche et
qu'elle fait exactement ce qu'elle veut
elle pouvait même introduire des bouts
de textes qui n'existaient pas encore
qui navaient été débattu ni à
l'Assemblée ni au Sénat donc il pouvait
tout faire mais est-ce que les
républicains du Sénat qui eux avaient
fait passer leur texte nétait pas en
position de for le gouvernement pouvait
également refuser de conclure la CMP et
aurait pu dans ces cas-là revenir à
l'Assemblée avec un texte qui a été
celui du Sénat et il aurait dit on
repasse en commission des lois on
détricote tout ce qui a été fait au
Sénat et ensuite on met au voix ce texte
là à l'Assemblée et même puisque ce
gouvernement a a utilisé le 493 à 23
reprises depuis 1 an et demi et bien ils
auraient même pu utiliser le 493 s'il
avait voulu et donc ils auraient pu
adopter le texte dans les conditions
précises dans lesquelles ils souhaitaent
qu'il soit adopté ils n'ont rien fait de
fait pas crédit Emmanuel macronit
d'avoir refusé le 493 justement sur ce
texte et d'avoir dit dès le début on le
fera pas passer par 493 mais je ne lui
fais crédit de rien du tout qu'est-ce
que vous voulez que je lui fasse crédit
en fait voilà quelqu'un qui en réalité
nous explique quand il devient président
de la République la première prère fois
et dans et je rappelle que il y a eu
déjà un épisode tragique pour enfin pour
la France et pour le gouvernement de
gauche à l'époque c'était le débat sur
la déchérance de nationalité à l'époque
Emmanuel Macron s'en distingue en disant
que lui ne l'aurait pas faite dans le
texte que nous connaissons il y a la
déchange de nationalité donc il était en
fait à ce moment-là il se présentait
comme celui qui avait salué Angela
Merkel qui avait été l'honneur de
l'Europe disait-il parce qu'elle avait
su accueillir un million de Syriens au
moment du conflit au moment de la guerre
en en Syrie cette fois-ci il a été réélu
avec nos voix j'ai appelé au nom des
socialistes à voter pour Emmanuel Macron
au deuxè tour de l'élection
présidentielle pour éviter précisément
que se mette en place le programme de
l'extrême droite il a dit lui président
de la République candidat à l'époque que
ce vote l'obligeait et qu'il serait un
barrage contre les idées de l'extrême
droite que fait-il aujourd'hui il adopte
mot pour mot mot pour mot le programme
du RN vous ne revoteriez pas auourd'
vous regrettez vous regrettez d'avoir
voté pour lui je je ne regrette pas
d'avoir fait battre marieenne Le Pen
mais évidemment je regrette aujourd'hui
d'avoir été
finalement
instrumentalisé par Emmanuel Macron qui
est coupable de haute trahison sur cette
question donc vous ne revoteriez pas
pour lui aujourd'hui pour faire barrage
à Marine Le Pen vous considérez qu'il
n'est plus un barrage à Marine Le Pen
quelqu'un qui applique le programme de
marieenne Le Pen et c'est le cas
aujourd'hui ne peut plus être présenté
comme un barrage à marieenne Le Pen et
ce que je vous disais en introduction
c'est que ce qui s'est passé hier est
extrêmement grave parce que ça fait
tomber aussi l'idée du barrage
républicain comment voulez-vous que
demain nous puissions appeler à voter
pour un candidat macroniste si devait se
représenter et j'espère qu'elle ne se
représentera pas mais comment
voulez-vous que nous appelions à voter
contre l'extrême droite alors que les
gens qui sont en face vont appliquer le
Pr l'extrêmeite mais vous l'avez entendu
hier Gérald rmanin dans son discours
devant les députés il vous a accusé vous
la gauche de trahir le peuple ben en
quoi trahissons-nous le peuple il dit
vous trahissez le peuple sur la question
du travail sur la question de laïcité
mais en quoi trahissons-nous le peuple
nous sommes nous sommesousours nous
sommes nous pour régularisé par le
travail nous sommes précisément pour
dire que c'est le travail qui permet
l'intégration donc comment comment
peut-on dire des choses aussi définitive
et aussi fausse la réalité c'est que
Géral daranin a toujours en fait et sur
un discours qui est un discours en
réalité populiste il est en train
d'épouser complètement les thèses qui
sont celles de l'extrême droite et je
rappelle que le même trouvait que
marineen Le Pen était trop molle par
rapport à lui bien malheureusement il en
fait la démonstration alors aujourd'hui
enfin hier plutôt une soixantaine de
voix ont manqué à la majorité de députés
de la majorité qui sont abstenus ont
voté contre ce texte plusieurs ministres
aujourd'hui menacent de démissionner
est-ce que pour vous on assiste à une
recomposition du clivage gauche- droite
puisque c'est essentiellement des
députés des ministres issus souvent du
PS qui qui ont cette position
aujourd'hui mais ce qui est sûr c'est
que c'est la fin d'un mythe il s'est
fait élire la première fois en
expliquant qu'il était et de gauche et
de droite on a compris assez rapidement
qu'il était de droite et de droite et
depuis hier soir on a compris qu'il
était de droite et d'extrême droite vous
dites aujourd'hui Emmanuel Macron est
d'extrême droite mais il applique un
programme qui est un programme d'extrême
droite c'est une ligne rouge qui devrait
être facilement perceptible pour tout le
monde et d'ailleurs je vois que certains
d'entre eux ont très bien compris ce
qu'il se passait si 62 d'entre eux ont
refusé de voter ce texte alors même
qu'ils sont plutôt dévoués au chefs de
l'État c'est bien qu'ils ont compris que
ils étaient en train de ils ne pouvaient
pas apposer leur nom en bas de ce
parcheminl Aurélien rousse juste
Aurélien Rousseau a présenter sa
démission 7ette nuit le ministre de la
Santé quen dit-vous oui ben si non
seulement il la présente mais il la
maintient puisque je vois que pour
l'instant on ne sait pas très bien si
elle a été acceptée ou pas par Matignon
enfin quand on veut démissionner on
démissionne on nattend pas en fait le
feu vert du président la première
ministre on ne fait pas une darin si
vous voyez ce que je veux dire c'est du
BL c'est de la come bah Darmanin c'était
de la comme pure il est venu présenter
sa démission en plus au président de la
République alors que en réalité c'est à
Matignon qu'on la présente quand on est
ministre enfin quand on a un peu lu la
5e République bon c'est pas visiblement
depuis quelques jours on comprend que
ils ont une vision des institutions qui
leurait très quia très singulière
puisque y compris la séparation des
pouvoirs et ça tout ça n'existe plus
avec eux mais enfin la réalité c'est que
Darman n'a jamais voulu démissionner il
est venu faire semblant à l'Élysée ils
ont pris un pot ensemble et puis il est
reparti en expliquant que il avait voulu
et puis en même temps le chef de l'État
avit pas voulu et donc voilà il allait
continuer parce qu'il devait faire son
devoir et puis les Jeux Olympiques et
cetera bon bref ce ce cinéma là ne
trompe personne donc maintenant on va
voir ce que fait rien Rousseau on va
voir si les cléments bon et autres
vergrit et cetera font en fait de leur
conviction l'alpha et
l'oméga de
de leur vie politique et si les
convictions sont plus fores que les
ambitions on verra on les jugera
finalement à ce qu'ils feront est-ce que
vous patrons du Parti socialiste vous
pourriez rediscuter avec cette aelle
gauche de la macronie qui aujourd'hui
n'est plus d'accord avec Emmanuel Macron
mais moi j'appelle ce matin tous les
républicains toutes celles et ceux qui
sont hostiles à ce texte à se parler et
à tout faire pour que le combat culturel
que nous devons mener puisse être mené
de concert sur la question migratoire
que nous puissions arriver à conjurer en
fait toutes ces fake news permanentes
qui sont diffusé du chef de l'État
jusqu'à Marine Le Pen et arriver à faire
en sorte que sur ce terrainlà nous
puissions nous mettre d'accord et faire
en sorte que notre pays accepte l'idée
que nous ne pouvons pas transformer
l'étranger en bouc émissaire beaucoup
viennent du PS viennent de de chez vous
est-ce que vous sentez encore des
valeurs copines avec un Stéphane traver
avec un sachat Houlier est-ce que vous
pourriez reconstruire quelque chose
ensemble bah c'est à eux de dire ce
qu'ils sont prêts à faire c'est à eux de
dire si ils ont simplement cherché à
laver leur conscience hier en se
refusant un vote qu'il savait déjà àquis
par les voies de la droite et de
l'extrême droite et donc mais pour vous
les liens sont pas rompus totalement
après leur départ chez moi je suis la
politique c'est des actes c'est pas
simplement des verbiages mais est-ce que
vous vous les appelez à revenir au PS
mais je les appelle à aller jusqu'au
bout de leur conviction si hier soir
leur vote était simplement une façon de
laver leur cons science en sachant très
bien que le texte serait adopté grâce
aux voix du RN et aux voix des
républicains et bien si ils veulent
aller jusqu'au bout de leur conviction
ils doivent rompre avec un pouvoir qui
est un pouvoir qui a fait le choix d'un
texte raciste et xénophobe ça c'est
effectivement quelque chose que
j'entendrais et que je comprendrais et
ça ce serait un acte qui serait un acte
puissant un acte fort un acte fondateur
qui les qualifierait effectivement pour
retrouver le reste de la gauche mais si
c'est simplement pour faire un pas de
côté et dire bon écoutez moi je suis
toujours avec le président hein donc
vous inquiétez pas Président je suis
toujours là avec vous hein je suis à
votre côté jusqu'à la fin mais bon j'ai
j'ai dit ça c'est vous comprenez c'est
pour dire quand même que vous avez
encore une aile gauche bon ça sert à
rien une aile gauche qui serait en fait
prête à approuver un texte d'extrême
droite ça ne sert à rien hier soir
manuel Bompard a demander une réunion de
laanupes pour prendre des initiatives
communes de son côté Jean-Luc Mélenchon
a proposé un bilan pour repartir sur de
bonnes bases on assiste à la renaissance
de l'anupess la suite de du vote de ce
texte moi je veux pas dans un moment
comme celui que nous vivons en rentrer
dans la
politique pas politicienne c'est
important les alliances et cetera mais
enfin je veux pas tout mélanger je dis
simplement que à Jean-Luc Mélenchon ce
serait utile que d'ors et déjà il
commence par ne pas tweeter n'importe
quoi n'importe comment et hier soir
quand il laisse penser quand même il dit
explicite cement qu'il y a un lien entre
le vote de la loi d'armanin et la
manifestation contre l'antisémitisme à
laquelle a participé l'extrême droite et
dans laquelle il pense que la matrice
même de ce texte c'est la manifestation
contre l'antisémitisme je dis que là il
y a quand même en fait beaucoup
d'efforts à réaliser avant que nous
puissions nous retrouver Mo je souhaite
moi je souhaite que la gauche puisse se
retrouver mais sur des bases qui soient
des bases clair des bases qui soient en
fait entendbles par tout le monde que
nous puissions continuer à parler à
ensemble des Français à nous élargir en
direction de toutes celles et ceux qui
hier ont dit non je pense au Secours
catholique je pense à Fr d'asile je
pense à la CFDT je pense à la CGT je
pense à toutes ces organisations qui ont
dit non au chefs de l'État et qui ont
dit que il n'était pas possible
d'accepter de renoncer à nos principes
les plus élémentaires un dernier mot
Olivier fort Emmanuel Macron doit
prendre la parole ce soir qu'est-ce que
vous en attendez je vous l'ai dit je
souhaite que compte tenu de l'émotion
suscité y compris dans ses propres rangs
il renonce à Prom promulguer ce texte
tout juste pas de promulgation vous
attendez rien d'autre du chef de l'État
mais que voulez-vous j'attende de lui en
fait pour l'instant j'ai l'impression
quand même que il était pas prêt à faire
un compromis quelconque avec la gauche
le choix qu'il a fait ça a été toujours
de négocier avec une droite extrémisée
qui vivait elle-même sous perfusion de
l'extrême droite et donc est-ce que vous
avez vu dans la suspension d' séance de
la CMP madame borne inviter un leader de
gauche quel qu'il soit à venir discuter
avec elle la réponse évidemment est non
et depuis un an et demi il ils n'ont de
regard Dieu de de chimen que pour la
droite extrémisé et donc nous n'avons
absolument pas de chos à attendre du
chef de l'État en revanche lui devrait
prendre conscience de ce qu'il fait il a
il a annoncé pour janvier une grande
initiative qui devait rassembler tous
les Français parce queil faut de l'unité
et C dans ce pays oui il faut de l'unité
et bien quand on veut de l'unité on
commence par ne pas fracturer jour après
jour son pays il l'a fait il y a moins
d'un an sur les retraites il le fait à
nouveau aujourd'hui sur la loi
immigration il est temps qu'il soit le
président de tous les Français merci
Olivier fort merci beaucoup d'avoir été
notre invité Christelle la Une de La
Dépêche la immigration la loi
empoisonnée c'est à la Une de votre
journal merci Christelle on passe au
club des territoires